yeah that's that stoicism right there
get a visualization for the stoicism
book I read to it yeah it's interesting
there's a whole cohort and value and
other folks who are I think when you hit
it big it it does [ __ ] with your mind a
little bit where you're like okay what
now
like there's two ways to have your mind
[ __ ] with I think it's like tragedy
yeah an abundance yes and I think a lot
of people in this town are struggling
with the abundance yeah and people get
weird I think that's that's right the
people struggle with the abundance and
then they don't know what to do cuz
there's no goal there's no more carrot
right and then or you can set a bigger
one but then you realize like oh I got
this one and I'm not any happier no so
what happened like that's the promise of
America is like oh you do this thing you
get this big cookie or whatever and boom
you're happy and then you get it and you
eat it and you're like I'm not any
happier that what happened so you can
even either like people go two ways or
you set a bigger goal or do you realize
like there's something else I there's
another axis I have to optimize for yeah
it's really interesting when you look at
like just entire nation states in China
they're thinking just about forget about
this higher order stuff like happiness
or ill worth or contentment or gratitude
there's a there's a billion people who
are like I want to have running water a
job a car and money and they're just
like Americans were you know at the turn
of the century you know hundred years
ago like I just want to be able to
produce my family I just want to
accumulate some wealth and you don't
have a car on the driveway and own a
home yeah and that's like what we're up
against is like a nine nine six culture
that just wants to make money and when I
spend time over there they're just like
it's just about making money yeah well
everyone every culture goes through its
phases right yeah like eventually people
care about the environment they live in
yep they start to care I mean this has
happened in the United States right in
the 70s like before we create the APA
like the US was like just crying yeah
we're destroying everything and then we
were like well we care about the
environment you get you know it's not
like a next phase on Maslow's heart you
got the environment on it but I care
about my mental health and then in
Europe they care about lifestyle so
just like and then what's very
interesting is your economic growth your
GDP is negatively correlated so like the
GDP of China
just whatever triple ours you know and
then ours is double or triple Europe's
so it's kind of like it goes around the
globe in this like oh yeah and then now
your negative growth in Europe and
they're like yeah but we take six weeks
vacation that's the ultimate end of end
of human evolution it might be as always
get this like very interesting pitch
from companies I work with the unlimited
vacation unlimited vacation is a fraud
as a company who where we had unlimited
vacation at a justin.tv
I think unlimited vacation is is is not
good I'm no longer proponent I think you
should because the people who take on
limit if occasion you actually don't
want to work at your company right what
you want is people to take a healthy
amount of vacation that's a fair amount
where they like disconnect and take a
break so they can come back and work
just you know hard right and you want to
just be clear about it like yes I think
it's unlimited vacation is like speaking
for myself you know not for other people
it's like what juvenile managers don't
know like who don't know how to like
talk to people about what's appropriate
vacation or not right take it's like
this ambiguous thing you just put out
there yeah I I'm not a I'm not an
unlimited vacation fan I was like really
weird advice that people give like
doesn't what do you think about the anti
hustle culture as we wrap up here like
it seems like people are a there's like
a formation now of like multiple camps
there's like zebra movement I don't if
you saw that in the New York term its
startups that either can't raise venture
capital or choose not to and they kind
of beat ups yeah but it's like
bootstrapping with a tinge of like VCS
or toxic I don't want to grow as fast as
VCS want to grow then there's like the
you know Gary Vaynerchuk way over here
hustle till you die wake up at 5:00 rise
and grind and those sort of people in
the middle it doesn't have to be crazy
at work maybe like the 37signals folks
where do you fall in that [ __ ] I think
you're still hustling right I'm hustling
but I'm still living my life like in a
reasonable way I mean at at atrium I
think we have a [ __ ]
working culture but it's not insane like
startup hmm I think that you really want
to think about sustainability
like what's the sustainable lifestyle
for you because sort of our marathons
are not Sprint's I think that is very
important that sustainability probably
involves some level of vacation some
level of like seeing your family you
know I think those things are very
important
so yeah this I don't have like I guess
I'm not dogmatic about it though because
the way I think about it is there are
many ways what I learned at Y Combinator
actually and like in my ears after
twitch was like there are many ways to
start a startup like I always tell if
I'm out always go to back to like beats
by dre it's like two celebrities start a
company and they completely outsource
the product to another company and it's
basically like a marketing company and
they they take you know they raise
hundreds of millions of dollars and
eventually there's like 900 million
dollars that they immediately pay to
themselves as a dividend you would not
think that that company would be
successful no on paper that sounds like
a Ponzi scheme right but then there's
raising 900 and distributing it to our
players and so welcome to the cap table
but yet it was right it was very
successful and so there are many I'm not
saying I would want to start a company
like that but I'm saying there are many
ways to start a company you can
bootstrap a company there's like the you
know Spanx like Sir Blakely yeah but
company you can bet you can raise a
shit-ton a venture capital and you can
start that sort of that company there's
so many different ways to do it you know
I don't think there's a rule right
obviously different cultures up so
cultures have their own rules that Gary
Vaynerchuk or Y Combinator how you sort
of start up or you know there's
different ways that people do it but I I
think that what I have learned from
meeting entrepreneurs all over the world
is that there's many ways to start a
company and you should find what works
for you yeah it's just different
playbooks yeah like you can go slow you
can grind it out so I could raise like
75 million very trim and go big is what
you chose to do now he's like well I
know it's gonna work I might as well go
for it was that to her thinking Zak I
was like I know it's gonna work my goal
is to really try something to do
something build something really fast
and and and big and with high impact and
I felt like this market existed I
understood the problem so I wasn't as
worried about like finding product
market fit
and so that's that's what we that's why
we kind of did away we did it
it's not the right way for everyone
right like I have a friend Peter who
found this company or x-bar right yeah I
love our x-bar yeah they didn't behind
you on the chef there we go there we go
sparked a partner for the show exact cuz
I eat them all time my trainer was like
eat this yeah it's like two egg it's two
egg whites and like six almonds and yeah
you're done yeah I'm like okay I may be
five of those a week I love them I know
your friends started that company
yeah and they so today I think they only
raised like a couple ten tens of
thousands of dollars from family or
something like that and then you know
they sold for seven million dollars so
so there are lots of ways like they're
it's I'm not the anti-v see people if
they're saying VC is toxic all the time
well no some of the greatest companies
in the world have been creative with VC
capital metric Apple twitch could never
been created without venture capital
because we didn't have 45 million
dollars in pay for servers yeah right
and getting as a founder 10% or whatever
you wound up with certainly less than
20% when you started yeah it's just fine
exactly exactly there because I there's
many different ways to do it right and
there's there's no right answer and I
think that people are looking for the
algorithm you know there's no olive oil
here it is you know no self-awareness I
thought you were gonna say the when I
asked you with that question what's
important in startups I didn't know
you're gonna go to software and I said
that was possibility my other guess what
you're gonna say
just building a product that really
helps people know well I thought I was
taking that forgive it refer grant
that's kind of that's kind of table
stakes today it is interesting you don't
build a product that people actually use
then yes what are we doing here yeah
exactly like you should get get a job
somewhere there's no yeah how did you
raise from like I have a list here of
your investors it's like 90 different
investors did you just email everybody
like a BCC like hey I'm starting a
company here you go did you action
figures Kickstarter no no we met with
all these investors you know we raise
money from from General Catalyst led the
series a and then injuries in this
there's B but we also raise money from
sound ventures Y Combinator SV angel
thrive founders fun Greylock first round
yeah yeah so many many many more bunkers
the our idea was that we wanted to build
a community of investors who would
support us and also you know we felt
like you know we wanted to market to
their portfolios and that makes total
sense so if you're build a better
mousetrap and they're investors they
might refer you exactly that's smart
all right ma'am listen this has been
great we could talk for hours and we did
one of my favorite founders and
considered individuals here in the
valley
living the dream he's still riding on
that motorcycle you haven't written in
at least a year okay I've been running
this jump bikes around and and jump
backs okay jump bikes and birds when
they weren't there in the city and then
I was gonna talk to you about this
because you you're married now yes kids
no kids but that's on the raw member
mayli yeah one day one day okay well how
do you know 3500 three six I know it's
35 and I'll turn 36 this year because
it's a year of the bore got it Chinese
New Year's Chinese New Year a day I just
got back from Hong Kong I had Peking
about three out of four meals and then I
roast pig the fourth know it's a good
time to have kids actually is it when
you're set up and your that's when I had
my first daughter once in my late
thirties so I have a nine-year-old
daughter and then I have twins who are
gonna be three years old in March so
that's the perfect time because you have
the resources yeah and you're mature but
you don't want to wait too much longer
no cuz then you start to get tired yes
and I'm 48 now and like I have to
workout to rebuild my energy so that I
can pick up twins also you have twins it
doubles the weight so instead of having
like a 30 pound daughter you have 60 60
pounds one on each arm it's good for
working out but it's actually a
priceless hammer curls yeah exactly no
it's a perfect time for you to yeah to
do it it's but I was gonna tell you
about that bike yeah people are bad
drivers here and they are on their phone
my god I saw wham-o car last night
and this is gonna sound wise cuz you
know brother family I mean they all
crash at some point but he just caught
off this guy I don't know if it was the
human driver whatever was like whoa
that's like definitely not cool not cool
yeah
yeah and just people are distracted like
stay off that I loved motorcycles I when
I was in Brooklyn I when I was 18 19
years old I would ride motorcycles and
every time I leave my mom would be on
the porch of the Browns
yeah when I leave I come back four hours
later you know what she'd be on the
porch on the porch waiting for me to get
home because she was a nurse yeah and
all she didn't she ran the emergency
room all she did was you know held her
psychodrama motorcycle trauma yeah Elan
almost died on one when he was a kid
it just it's too dangerous I actually
haven't written in your yeah no it's
like my two things I tell I have a lot
of friends who either want to become
pilots which is it alluring two founders
yeah or ride motorcycles which is super
alluring to the same type of people want
to be founders yeah like they're
independent you know you know technical
yeah you get your own space you get on
your adventure yeah it's like
adventurous and you know it's just those
two things
motorcycles maybe if you're in a place
where you're like riding in the hills
where there's no cars like yeah totally
get it like if you drove down the PCH or
something deal but man in this city
watching people drive with their phones
out like oh yeah he's gotten way worse
people are like on their phone feet on
Facebook or Instagram or something while
they're driving down the road it's
bonkers people gonna die stay off that
motorcycle and if you want to do pilot
for those friends of mine warm to pilot
just get a copilot if you can afford to
have a plane and do this you gotta for a
co-pilot yep who does it for a living
case you make a mistake see that's what
I want except I don't want to be the
pilot at all I want to just be flown
somewhere it's for private jet yes you
want a private what you're talking about
is atrium being sold for five billion
and then you get your finally get your
gen it's the only thing left is a jet if
I finally got a sports team if I get
that jet I'll finally finally I'll be
happy I know that a my happiness as a
joke is not the jet you know it's owning
the Knicks there sorry I just tweeted
the other day that I'm decided under the
word for the next ten years and invest
in 100 companies a year just for the
explicit purpose of like building a
model that results in me owning the
Knicks yes at sixty twelve years from
now it'll be 60 years old I'll buy the
Knicks and then have 20 years of life
left hopefully yes to win a championship
for New York and then I'll be highly be
happy if that if I'm on if I hold that
trophy on the Canyon of Heroes in New
York and bring a championship to the
Knickerbocker
my team which hasn't won since 73 I will
finally be happy it's only gonna take
another 32 years and seven billion
dollars which is the current value of
the Knickerbockers and the garden in new
york all right Thank You Emmy Award
winning producer Jackie it's episode 999
unicorn founders and investors to go
Jackie you have your marching orders the
last the next hundred episodes all
unicorn founders and the next episode is
going to be the founder of SendGrid Wow
also a unicorns unicorns on unicorns on
unicorns unicorns on unicorns on
unicorns on unicorns okay
great job Justin and we'll see you all
next time in sweet cyrus very much
[Music]